ma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous nous je veux pas devenir maîtresse
d'école
j'aime pas d'écho y moi ce que je veux
faire quand je serai grande mois moi je
veux devenir actrice ouais avec plein de
gens j'aimerais jouer j'aimerais écrire
des pièces pour que les gens y soient
heureux parce que moi j'aime quand les
gens ils sont heureux ouais moi j'aime
pas quand le monde il est triste moi je
veux changer les moudre là je me revoilà
quatre ans avec mes couettes
je voulais faire que ça actrice écrire
des pièces et avec ça je me disais n'y a
pas d'autre métier dans la vie il n'y
avait que ça il y avait que ça elle
voulait être comédienne a elle fini
fonctionnaires 1 dans un bureau a alors
franchement as tu me déçois c'est jérémy
monde veut 17 ans il est avec moi
impitoyable non mais franchement tati
terrain gardes tu es devenu un bichon
domestiques et non maman m'a dit que tu
étais une petite fille original plein de
talent nan mais franchement way dont je
m'occupe des soir non écoute un jérémy
tu me parles sur un autre ton d'abord
fonctionnaires moi c'est un job que
j'aime c'est un c'est un job sur j'ai
l'impression d' amener des choses faut
pas oublier une chose je reçois aussi
des gens dans mon bureau qui cherchent
un travail c'est pas facile
d'accord et puis la deuxième chose je
fais du théâtre
ça fait dix ans que je fais du théâtre
jeux
ou par ci par là qui excuse moi j'ai
rédigé pas de comptes à rendre mais faut
bien payer ses factures
il faut bien payer ces facteurs est et
tu parles comme les vieux
non mais franchement elle est où elle
est où ariane qui voulaient décoller qui
voulait changer le monde hein c'est pas
dans ce bureau que tu vas tu va décoller
la battue va plutôt cloués au sol ma
pauvre non c'est vraiment dommage tu me
fais de la paix non non tu veux que je
te dise était une artiste de salon as tu
vivotait non-écoute jérémy tu peux pas
me parler comme ça parce que tu connais
pas la vie que je mène tu connais pas le
quotidien mon quotidien
parce que mon travail jérémy et ben
c'est ça oui bonjour madame je vous en
prie je vous en prie asseyez vous y
voilà
non je vous en prie alors je vous écoute
je désolé madame borel je suis désolé je
ne devrais pas c'est là que je me lâche
coûté g j'ai perdu mon travail et
comment vous dire c'est que je me sens
mais démunis parce que au delà du fait
que j'ai perdu mon travail
excusez moi or email au-delà de ça j'ai
l'impression de wingene l'impression
d'avoir perdu mon identité
ça c'est une scène soutenable écoutez
madame je comprends tout à fait votre
désarroi 1 mais vraiment on va trouver
des solutions on va mettre un plan
d'action ensemble on va mettre une
stratégie en somme je suis payé pour ça
on trouvera des solutions et s'il vous
plaît s'il vous plaît votre identité n'a
rien à voir avec la perte de votre
travail vous avez de la valeur madame ça
suffit s'il vous plaît madame
reprenaient confiance en vous alors tu
vois jérémy 1
tu vois ce que je vis tous les jours des
gens qui cherchent un travail comme
c'est difficile aujourd'hui de trouver
un travail quand on l'a perdu 1
alors tu me vois moi un leur dire oui
vous savez au fond je suis une artiste à
et puis je vais donner mon congé je vais
lâcher le japon comprenez moi la vie à
ces gens ils cherchent un boulot hein
j'aurais comment te dire j'aurais
vraiment vraiment l'impression de bois
de linars gay j'aurais vraiment
l'impression je sais pas de vraiment
d'être way d'être irresponsable ouais
ouais tu fais comme tu veux moi je te
dis que c'est juste dommage suis pas en
train de critiquer la fonction octets
que tu es dans un bureau avec des gens
etc
c'est super ce que tu fais mais
franchement je te vois pas confiné dans
un bureau un mois je te vois dans un
boulot là mais plutôt sur scène c'est ça
que je veux dire
t'a abandonné tes rêves excuse moi tu as
la trouille la vérité 1 tu fais quand
même dû sous régime tati j'suis désolé
arrive énerve mais la raison il a raison
je fais du sous régime
si j'en avais je dirais j'en ai pas
j'ai la trouille mais j'ai la trouille
oui j'ai la trouille de lâcher mon job
pour vivre de mon art
parce que y'a pas que moi dans cette
histoire quand je rencontre des gens mon
entourage mais les gens ils sont comme
moi hein on fait dans notre froc
on a peur jeu j'aimerais bien vivre de
mon art ouais bah qu'est ce que tu veux
c'est pas facile la vie un non c'est pas
facile tu voudrais pas un peu non à
l'habitude c'est lâcher ton job comme ça
à ton âge faut bien payer ses factures
ouais vous bien veilleux eyed peas qui a
pas seulement ça y'a pas seulement payer
ses factures
il ya aussi l'éducation on a une
éducation ouais c'est pas la faute de
nos parents mais je sais pas nous a pas
appris à écouter notre petite voix
intérieure qui est la nôtre grosse voix
intérieure qu'elle a way notre petite
voix intérieure c'est ça ces fins qui
est juste
ces cinq et réaliste c'est pas la
réalité qu'on nous impose
c'est ça et puis et puis tout à coup
j'ai retrouvé une amie d'enfance que
j'avais pas revu depuis longtemps
christine lots christine et
j'ai rencontré un homme mon nouvel
amoureux alain et les deux ans coeur me
dise comme ça dans un élan mais du livre
de ton art mais vas-y et attendent quoi
mais vas-y cet avis est ta respiration
ces tombes où le théâtre mais vas-y mais
fons tu t'appelles ariane décolle
[Rires]
ouais ouais ans et ils m'ont dit une
phrase ils m'ont dit mais on croit en
toi
il croit en moi et ça
cette solidarité c c'est beau c'est
précieux
et là et là par la peur à tourner avant
avant j'avais peur de tout perdre et
tout à coup on voit tout à coup
mais mais tout à coup j'ai eu peur de me
perdre
non hélas mon théâtre apparu comme une
évidence il le théâtre est venu à moi je
me suis dit n'est mais qu'est ce que
j'attends mais qu'est ce que j'attends
pour écrire pour faire du théâtre à
plein temps tout ce que je vois au
travail dans la vie de dénoncer les
injustices
non pas dans un bureau mais sur scène
les peines des gens leurs souffrances
leurs plaies leur joie mais sur scène à
échelle large public large mais c'est ça
ma vie comme une évidence
et là au fond qu'est ce que je vois je
vois une petite ariane là bas assis sur
un banc avec ses mains sous ses fesses
qui balance ses jambes dans le vide et
elle me regarde et elle me dit anticiper
tissier justifié haha tu as des jolies
chaussures oui elles sont vernis mais
oui tu sais moi j'aimerais bien qu'on y
aille
tu fait long jeanny marc ouais tu as
raison on va y aller viens viens viens
voilà et là le train de la confiance est
entré en gare
ouais le train de la confiance est entré
en gare et j'ai tout lâché j'ai tout
lâché j'ai tout quitté
j'ai tout lâché j'ai tout ip ça y est ça
y est enfin
enfin je suis dans ma vie je suis
pleinement ariane totalement et vous
savez quoi vous vous qui êtes dans cette
salle je vous demande est-ce que vous
êtes prêts est-ce que vous êtes prêts à
vivre à vivre votre rêve
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]